used it heavily in the past. Would you say that your position
on the usage of CF has changed or is there any or is there another
take? Why my stance has never changed. People just like to pretend
that it has changed, but it has never changed. If you want to
talk about people on the internet, be it Kiwi Farms or some other
place. I mean, I think you should have a right to do that. They
want to get Kiwi Farms. Um but Kiwi Farms basically ends up taking
the fall or getting the blame for literally everything. Even
though um even though a lot of the stuff like the Uber Eatats
hacks, like the swattings and the doxings, like there was that
one swatting that didn't even happen. the person emailed me and
told me that they called the police. Um, I just don't think it's
right that like Kiwi Farms is getting like the blame for every
single bad set on the internet. When you've used it heavily in
the past, would you say that your position on the usage of KF
has changed or is there any or there's another take? Why my stance
has never changed? People just like to pretend that it has changed,
but it has never changed. Oh, whoops. So, here's kind of what
happens. Kiwi Farms is the most visible site on the internet
that does harassment, but there's a lot of other things that
exist in the background that are arguably responsible for more.
And none of those websites are ever brought up because there's
no glory in chasing those websites. People want to slay the dragon.
They want to get kiwi farms.
But did all of the bad things that have happened to her over
the past several months and blamed me for her doxing. There is
no proof or evidence of any of this. I cannot.
Apparently Kebles was my first rolling. Keep us rolling. I only
be blamed for Kiwi Farms creating a threat on her when I had
no involvement in it. Again, the
Wow. Oh my god. Interesting. Wow. Wow. Why don't we maintain
this logic now with anything?
My god. You'd think it's like I I here are unwell. Um but there's
a website called Kiwi Farms that generally is supposed to just
be like uh we talk about or obsess over people that we deem worthy
of obsession. Um generally they're not supposed to interfere
too much with them. That used to be the old rules. But um for
my life I guess K Farms has decided that they're like a full
activist like we're going to do every possible thing that we
can to [__] with this person and all the people around
him cuz that's just what they do. You bring them into his circle
and you know he woos them and then you know oh like all of this
stuff the these are all just like Kiwi Farms narratives that
just get like perpetuated. It's narrative control and then it's
how many people around this person can we harass or can we um
dox or swat or whatever and like that's just the goal for all
of it. Um just fine. I don't care. Um, but to have like Kiwi
Farms to be like a like doxing swatting central that all these
other content creators, so all the commentary community people,
um, all of the lefties, all of everybody else has no problem
and justical the people who are skeptical of the Kiwi Farms angle.
Didn't you get a good chunk of your info on Keles's from Kiwi
Farms and participate in the threads? Um, did I post in Ke's
thread? I feel like I posted in my own thread a couple times
to to to search up, which worked spectacularly. Um, but I most
of the research that I did for the Keel stuff was research I
ended up doing on my own. Um, cuz a lot of it just came from
videos that she posted in conversations that she had. So that
narrative is directly from Chis himself, by the way. Yeah. Some
people call me some people want to call me a hypocrite because
they'll say, "I defended Kiwi Farms in the past and now I'm anti-
Kiwi Farms because they're mean to me." Um, that's the narrative
that Kiwi Farms wants to sell. And Joshua wants to sell that,
too, because he's literally like he's trying to control the infighting
in my thread to direct people to be activists against me, which
is hilarious and not even what like the farms is supposed to
be for, but okay. Another mentally ill woman that Destiny had
a long conflict with was a woman named Anna. Just like with Lav,
Destiny also encouraged his community to go to Anna's Kiwi Farms
thread and he encouraged them to post in her thread. Oh, okay.
Also, heads up, this is my only non-media blackout time. Okay,
this is my only non- media blackout time over media. Okay, somebody
on Kiwi Farms has made a thread of Anna. So, if you are obsessed
with Anna and you want to talk about her all the time, you chat
her. You can actually go to Kiwi Farms and you can go and post
all you want, read all you want. That go there, post about it,
talk about it. People put a a lot of effort into categorizing
and archiving everything. There you go. Okay. And in the thread
about Anna that Destiny encouraged his fans to go message, they
doxed Anna. Um, you It's weird cuz you did the whole Mr. Girl
report review. I think you went through theore section and then
when Destiny said, "I didn't do anything like manipulative."
Um, it literally says that they were two days before he posted
her Kiwi Farms thing. And then he goes, "Well, I didn't do that
to like with her." I did that to like get it out of my community.
And then when we go to the DMs, like if you want to stay in this
uh Anna says, "What the is wrong with you, dude? You just outed
that Kiwi Farm about me, dude. You are horrible." He says, "I
have a media blackout related to your stuff, and I wanted to
get everyone Oh, I'm covering this up for stream." Well, you
guys aren't going to see it. You'll see Connor's face. I have
a media blackout related to your stuff and I wanted to everyone
to get it out before uh people were talking about it incessantly
over the next two weeks as more and more people discovered it
which is like okay you are constantly the second paragraph is
where um when he says oh I didn't do it to like make her stop
talking about I didn't do it to do you are constantly talking
about me on your stream so I think it's fair for me to bring
it up you went as far to say I I was abusive to you the last
time you mentioned me she says because you threatened to leak
my no news you sociopath you literally ruined my life you just
doxed me on stream You put me in danger. You're doing it. He
says, "You're doing it to yourself. You're going to keep doing
it to yourself. You keep talking about me. Even if I say something
like, "I'm going to leak your nudes if you talk about me anymore."
Uh, you're doing it to yourself, actually. So, I would say this
is very much, hey, you have to stop what you're doing and I will
dox you and terrorize you and I'm justified in doing that because
you have talked about me in somebody's military career. No, it's
all part of Kiwi Farms is just basically a website where you
try to basically log all the information about a person you might
think is
Yeah. No, they take like people who are otherwise anonymous on
the internet. Um, no, they don't. Kiwi Farms doesn't care about
anonymous people. No, they don't. They usually follow like many
like like online eelebs and that's what the whole point of Kiwi
Farms is milking cows that are funny on the internet. You wouldn't
just like you wouldn't post like your thread would get deleted
for no relevance. Like I've never been on you. You haven't. If
you think they just do random people. I have. I have. I have
places like Kiwi Farms. It's kind of you're kind of like beyond
any normal person at that point. Like guys, like there's websites
that are being taken off the internet like for bad reasons. Like
really? What kind of sites? Okay. Well, there's a site called
Kiwi Farms. Like what do they do there? Well, you know, it's
we it's like a bunch of people that like obsess over laws on
like what's the law like? Okay. Well, like if I explain this
to you, it's going to be really weird. It's like, okay, well,
I don't know if I even care about this site. It sounds weird,
you know? Like that's the issue is that like all of the things
that are being affected around it are kind of things at the fringe,
right? Like even for my stuff like oh like I'm a big lefty, you
know, SJW and I got banned from Twitter and it's not fair. And
it's like really damn. like what kind of stuff did you tweet?
Well, you know, I told a woman to get by a shovel once, so I
like more. But um the issue that I have with Chudlo Logic is
that Chudlo Logic hosts the Kiwi Farms equivalent of um on Discord,
which is Spicy Chat, which is basically is another group of people
that are obsessed with me. Um and talk about my [__]
way too much, but it's just like a crazy um it's like a Kiwi
Farms Light except it exists on Discord and it's like a community
that Chad Logic hosts that I didn't want like any closess to.
Address logistical stuff is super annoying all over his socials.
He's claiming that people are trying to kill him because of you.
Uh, he's lying. Logistical like Queen. I'd kill him if I could.
I'd choke the house and do it. Um, but not for I do want somebody
to logistical though or laugh or Mr. Girl or Queen. Those people
can all die. Uh, uh, like people on Kiwi Farms are like, "Has
this guy ever been doxed before?" Genuine question. I know nothing
about this guy. I know that he's just L cow, but I've always
found him so boring. I've never seen any of his dramas. Like
it like if you even say something polite about me. Um, there
are people on this thread who will and they say they're like
they're open about it. They're like, "This guy's near destiny.
I'm going to dox this guy." And heads up, this is my only non-media
blackout time. Okay, this is my only non- media black time where
immediately like this. Okay, somebody on Kiwi Farms has made
a thread of Anna. So, if you are obsessed with Anna and you want
to talk about her all the time, you chatter. You can actually
go to Kiwi Farms and you can go and post all you want, read all
you want, go there, post about it, talk about it. Actually, let's
just do this because this is going to be funny. There's like
a couple random things here, but hold on. Did you see Did you
see this? Yes, he's been following the Splinter Discord drama.
Quan, he probably watched that that video and he came over to
my house into my home recording studio and we recorded this is
he brings up recent alleged issues found in Jtock's Discord and
Kelly's Discord footage from that. Guy has millions of dollars
by the way. Millions of dollars watching Chris Blood. What's
going on? millions of dollars and he is uh well just listen to
how he explains these things up too much but just so like just
as a quick example of this um so one of the things that I brought
up before okay because um people like I hate bringing up this
name I going to talk about it for two days now u people so I
bring up like on just people's discord server right so what they'll
do is and what all these communities do the reason why people
read these snark things is because other side communities will
take everything from there and then they'll repost it and they'll
play stupid so I think like just to go on his stream was like
what we don't do any of this what are you talking about side
discord servers what who what do you even know one even does
anything, right? So, like Kelly, for instance, who's now perman
by the way is not I somebody else must have sped this up like
making all these side discords, right? I don't I don't would
I have claimed that there is no like Splinter Discords for mine.
I feel like I wouldn't I feel like that's an explicit problem.
It's just like he's just doing this. Yeah, it's like totally
It's webbing. That's what it is. It's like just guilt by association.
Like it's it's honestly like a little be like he literally is
just inventing things. Like he actually is, he goes on, he's
just like actually maliciously inventing a narrative out of nothing.
Everybody making a new general to wipe this Discord because people
keep getting reported lol because they're just like they do insane
unhinged on all these servers. And then they talk about this
is a DJ is reporting most of the people in these servers by the
way. Um and the thing Kelly's banned for is actually chastising
other people for having posted pictures of her in lingerie because
they didn't realize she was underage at the time. I don't know
her exact age, but people were like, "Oh, look at these pictures
of people Kelly." And she's like, "Actually, that little like
10 pixel photo, this is uh I'm underage there. You should delete
that." And her getting mad at somebody who posted that is her
getting banned from the server apparently or getting her Discord
account perma banned cuz she was like, "Hey, you did this before."
By the way, it wasn't for that picture being posted. I don't
think the person who posted the picture got banned. It was her
saying it's up that you did that. She got perma banned for that.
None of, by the way, not perma banned for any of her comments
on Destiny's girlfriend's. just purely for her being like, "Hey,
it's weird that you posted pictures of me when I was young."
Like going through um uh oh yeah, like me and Juice have been
doing a ton of bands on other accounts cuz we don't know who
these people are. And the reason why they do this is just so
that they can repost and talk all this insane every single day
for weeks and weeks and weeks and weeks and weeks. This is talking
about like people who joined with Nina Nongrada. You know Nina
Nangrada, the person who's like super skitso, super skitso on
Discord. She's she's deranged about Yeah. Yes. Yes. Yes. That's
um that's who this is talking about. Somebody Destiny knows who
that is. But she's like suspending like sus accounts. What does
he even say here? Like they do insane unhinged on all these servers.
And then they talk about like going through um uh Oh yeah, like
me and J have been doing a ton of bands on other accounts cuz
we don't know who these people are. And the reason why they do
this is just so that they can repost and talk all this insane
every single day for weeks and weeks and weeks and weeks and
weeks. what they So, I guess he's trying to explain like why
to people like why he wouldn't have evidence of any of this.
But I'm curious why he actually would be saying this. Like obviously
if he was going to make all these assertions, he would already
have been shown the evidence, right? So, he just should have
that sitting in a Discord DM somewhere. Now, now he seems to
be claiming that like, oh, I I won't be able to find it cuz they've
deleted all of it. Yeah. Anyway, this is um not This is literally
I think Jub and Kelly trying to get rid of those weird people
that came in before. do it enough so that it gets filtered out
through the larger streamers and then you have your jigs and
your queens that report it for like my stuff and then it gets
picked up by commentary people and that's kind of like how the
funnel works. Um, like Kelly is talking about I don't really
want to post. I don't want to give links to her. But like Kelly,
so she's talking about my girlfriend, how my girlfriend deserves
all the bad that Kelly is like obsessed with saying about it.
And then Kelly's just talking about all of the different gossip
forums, um, including Kiwi forms and other places where she's
reading and getting the information from and it's like what the
but she's saying this in a side Discord server that she doesn't
know that I know exists and it doesn't show up as evidently in
the Jessica server, although it's hard to say because now every
single person there will delete all of their messages at the
end of every single day to keep it like untraceable or whatever.
So, because DJs have been mass reporting my discord, um, people
probably do run like redact or something now so they don't get
reported like mass reported over and over again. Um, imagine
deleting messages. Who would do such a thing? What a horrible
thing to do. That's crazy. Especially when you might have especially
when you might be accused of wrongdoing because it wasn't those
messages. That'd be terrible. But also, did you just see that
he claimed that like apparently the Kelly Discord is like a secret
Discord, a secret or hidden discord that I definitely haven't
complained about and I definitely haven't talked about in a 4hour
long bod [__] Discord exists that I haven't like
commissioned uh commissioned artwork of like a little meme, like
a little uh seven layers of hell meme about like all of the Splinter
Discord servers that exist and go on. I he's like actually on
so many levels of just like conspiratorial I I can't tell if
he's like actually having like a schizotypical meltdown or if
he's just lying blatantly blatantly he's just trying I assume
lying narratives about how Discords are targeting him and so
that he can justify attacking them I guess but which they've
been doing for over a month now but um that's just in regards
to my stuff personally but how do people continue to take this
argument seriously that like everybody apparently just stole
the Kele's tech I I heard Ethan do too. Like, oh, look, these
people reference Snark. They reference Snark in the video. We
don't have to take it seriously. It's like, dude, just contend
with the information. Mhm. Yeah, they just contend with the information.
It's also like it it works in regards to this stuff as well.
Um like the um the the But now this is going to be I really hope
this is relevant. Is this I mean, they were notorious for harassment
before. You say that, but I think a lot of the harass I think
that what happens is so here's kind of what happens. Kiwi Farms
is the most visible site on the internet that does harassment,
but there's a lot of other things that exist in the background
that are arguably responsible for more. And none of those websites
are ever brought up because there's no glory in chasing those
websites. People want to slay the dragon. They want to get Kiwi
Farms.
But this is when we did the whole we're not going to talk about
Doc Spin and how they clearly harassed Keles. Yeah. um farms
basically ends up taking the we mentioned this earlier today
as well fall or getting the blame for literally everything even
though um even though a lot of the stuff like the Uber Eats hacks
like the swattings and the doxings like there was that one well
and the sad thing is is like I would just love to know when Destiny
was swatted because I know at least one of them was like that
was before any of this blew up, right? Like Nathan was there
like he talked about it. Oh yeah, that was the Trump one, right?
It was the Trump one, I'm pretty sure. And I'm wondering when
the other swattings were because apparently he got swatted and
he like absolutely implied it was you or me or whoever who's
to blame for it. You actually we actually bear a quantum responsibility
for everything wrong that has ever been done to Destiny since
he was a child. Well, yeah. And like all of the doxing of all
of his friends happened before we covered this stuff too as far
as I know. Right. Like it's not like his girlfriend got doxed
or something like uh or aid or what whoever got doxed. It's not
like any of those people got doxed after the coverage. It was
all before. How how the are we responsible for the docses that
happened before and the swattings that happened before? Yep.
Well, like I said, it's quantum responsibility. It goes back.
It goes backwards. Happened. One person emailed me and told me
that they called the police. Um I just don't think it's right
that like Kiwi Farms is getting like the blame for every single
bad site on the internet. Now, if you want to see the It's not
right. Okay. It's just not right that Kiwi Farms is getting the
blame for every other bad site on the internet.
Oh my god. No, Jason Discord can get the blame for Kiwi Farms,
though emailed me and told me that they called the police. I
just don't think it's right that like Kiwi Farms is getting like
the blame for every single bad set on the internet. Now, if you
want to see that Kiwi Farm should get nuked off the internet
for doxing, um fine, but like it has to be for doxing like um
it can't be made up other you can't attribute. And like the problem
that I have too is that Wow. Wow. This is uh I don't know. I
I just I hope at some point like some of the completely people
who are still in the chat like the Douggee Chan guy, I hope they'll
look at this and just see this person is like literally the biggest
hypocrite in the entire world. Like he literally has no principles
or anything he stands for at all. But I Yeah. Well, Seri, he
talked about his position on KF today. He did. I don't know if
it's a new thing or not thing. I don't know. like these weird
like anti-fan places will pop up where they're these people who
are obsessed with like writing a certain story or narrative about
somebody and then when they do it all the other communities will
pick the information up and then it proliferates from there basically
but somehow all of these side communities like pretend um pretend
that that's not what's happening basically you know and it's
just it's yeah it's so to be like oh I can't believe that Ethan
would read this stuff it's not healthy like well it's going to
show up in a song video probably in two weeks anyways you know
this is
wow Ian has to watch song yeah well well in the video and he
came over to my house and to my home recording studio and We
recorded this is uh footage from that and we talked for over
3 hours and I at some point said I think we should probably cut
this off and we were having a really in-depth conversation. A
lot of us ups and down. Can you give me a long Kelly being banned
from Discord? Um there was some weird child thing that popped
up with justical server I think a couple months ago. It was like
after they couldn't obsessively talk about my stuff as much.
Something weird happened and a bunch of people in the server
either got banned or left the server. I don't know exactly what
happened. Um wow. I don't is there was a child thing that happened
and and a really weird thing happened after they couldn't talk
about him and everyone left the issue so the issues right now
Discord has if you report people for child endangerment you can
basically report I I don't really want to say it but basically
like the sensitivity on this thing is insane like essentially
if you've talked about kids in any context whatsoever you can
probably be suspended from Discord um there are huge videos of
massive Discords losing thousands of members to this right and
it's just a broadly known issue and somebody took that and they've
applied it to like my discord where there's like a script or
a bot or something that auto reports messages. So yeah, we've
had like a bunch of drop off in activity because while somebody
is running this stuff and reporting all of my then like it's
going to people are keep going to going to keep getting reported
and Kelly I think was one of those accounts rip but I don't have
Kelly again her message being it's weird that you guys shared
pics of me when I was underage or something like that that she
was perma banned for all the details for that. I at some point
said, "I think we should probably cut this off." And we're having
a really in-depth conversation, a lot of ups and downs. And so,
oh, and then he talks about Kiwi Farms. I hand over all of the
footage. I just gave it to him. I was thinking I wasn't going
to be in the video cuz I was thinking, how in the world content
in his style? How could he use anything that we said in in that
video because it was so slow and, you know, in my yammering way.
I see a lot of people argue that it's hypocritical for you to
criticize the use or mention of kiwi farms when you've used it
heavily in the past. Would you say that your position on the
usage of KF has changed or is there any is there another take?
My stance has never changed. People just like to pretend that
it has changed, but it has never changed. Oh, whoops. one swatting
that didn't even happen. The person emailed me and told me that
they up the internet for doxing. Um, fine. But the dragon they
want to get Kiwi Farm most visible site on the internet. I need
that. I need the actual clip again of him. Hold on. I'm going
to line this up. I'm going to line this up. I mean, they were
notorious for harassment before. Lot of other things. None of
those websites are ever brought up because there's no glory in
chasing ends up taking the fall or getting the blame. They want
to get Kiwi Farms. Um, but Kiwi Farms basically ends up taking
the fall or getting the blame for literally everything. Even
though um even though a lot of the stuff like the Uber Eats hacks,
like the swattings and the doxings, like there was that one swatting
that didn't even happen. The person emailed me and told me that
they called the police. Um I just don't think it's right that
like Kiwi Farms is getting like the blame for every single bad
set on the internet. Now, if you want to see that Kiwi Farm should
get nuked off the internet for doxing, I missed the mark. Honestly,
we've we've totally up. But this is like an example of one person
who got banned, by the way. Uh so next, Callum is going to say
he loves CPS. This is in regards to the Ethan Klein drama. This
person got timed out from Discord. Got banned from Discord for
I can't tell how long.
Yeah, you broke the rules for child safety. So there's And by
the way, they they I believe they um challenged this and we're
told no. Basically like no. Like these are the level of messages
that are getting people kicked out and it doesn't matter to anyone.
It's uh try talking to Discord. Discord doesn't respond. There's
no way to talk to Discord. It's crazy. Sorry. He was saying his
uh opinion on calf has never changed. Is there any is there another
take my stance has never changed. People just like to pretend
that it has changed when it has never changed. If you want to
talk about people on the internet be it kiwi farms or some other
place. I mean I think you should have a right to do that and
trying to tank websites like that down by attacking like the
registars or attacking be like credit companies. I don't think
that's necessarily I don't think that's a good thing. I think
if you want to make it illegal then pass a law or try to do something
like that. Um but like my stance on that has always been the
same. I still feel the same way about that. But people are in
this weird world where they're like oh you think this person
should have a right to say this thing that must mean that you
agree with it and you don't hate it. No. What? That's like I
can defend somebody's right to say something. He just totally
made up entirely what his position was and still think what they
say. Dude, what is this guy even talking about? You have a right
to say it, but also I think it would be just you for it. Like
that doesn't make any sense. You idiot. It's nonsensical. It's
completely nonsensical. It's like embarrassingly nonsensical.
But people still watch this guy. People are like, "Yeah, this
guy's really tapped. He's tuned in. He's tapped in. He knows
what he's talking about." I It's like it wasn't this bad before,
right? Like Like he This is the worst it's ever been, right?
He's never forced narratives through that are this square square
peg in the round hole level that's happening here. I have at
least I have to tell myself that to not myself uh in a video
game. Twitch in a video game. Okay, hold on. I just need I need
to go back here. So when I handed over all of the footage, I
just gave it to him. I was thinking I wasn't going to be in the
video because I was thinking how in the world content in his
style, how could he use anything that he said in in that video
because it was so slow and you know in my yammering way. I see
a lot of people argue that it's hypocritical for you to criticize
the use or mention of kiwi farms when you've used it heavily
in the past. Would you say that your position on the usage of
CF has changed or is there any there's another chance has never
changed. People just like to pretend that it has changed but
it has never changed. If you want to talk about people on the
internet be it Kiwi Farms or some other place I mean I think
you should have a right to do that and trying to take websites
like that down by attacking like the registars or attacking the
like credit companies. I don't think that's necessarily Oh, I
this. Hold on. What is this? What is this? On August 21st, she
claimed that I have actively facilitated all of the bad things
that have happened to her over the past several months and blamed
me for her doxing. There is no proof or evidence of any of this.
I
cannot apparently debate.
Keep us rolling. Keep us rolling. I only be blamed for Kiwi Farms
creating a threat on her when I had no involvement in it. Again,
the only
Wow. Oh my god. Interesting. Wow. Wow. Why don't we maintain
this logic now with anything?
My god. You'd think it's like I I dude y me personally me personally
as a as a liberal. I think I'm responsible for my actions. You
know, am I responsible for some influence of, you know, what
I send out? Sure. Yeah. But fundamentally, my actions and I should
be held accountable to what I've done. Now, apparently there's
a bunch of other people running around that think you should
be held accountable for what? People you don't even talk to.
People you've got you have no interaction with that you share
a Discord server with. Apparently, even the ones people you don't,
people that are in when when you share a Discord server with
someone who posts on the same website as someone else, you're
responsible for that third person's actions. So, me personally,
I think we should be held accountable for our own crimes. If
Destiny's this a liberal, then I mean that's that's his prerogative,
I guess. If he's not a liberal, then remember when the worst
thing you could be was illiberal. Remember? Yeah, I I remember
they had to cut Vos out. They had to cut Hassan out. Hassan is
like the worst person ever because he's illiberal. FD Signifier
is the worst person ever because he's illiberal. Vos, they hate
the rule of law. They hate the justice system. They they hate
democracy. They think you're responsible for, you know, everything
your race does. It's you're responsible for a date on the other
side of the world. You're a Jew, dude. I Oh,
hold on. I don't I I wonder if he only time I posted her thread
in my chat was to counter the allegations that most of the harassment
she received came from my community by proving the existence
of a Kiwi Farms thread. Oh, on her. Oh, so he actually posted
her Kiwi Farms thread. I I don't know if I've ever done that,
actually. On August. What about you, Queen? Have you posted his
Kiwi Farms thread somewhere? I honestly might. I've got no idea,
but it would have been a long time ago if I did. I haven't linked
for sure. Probably Yeah, probably before that, right? Probably
post. That's probably what I've linked.
Ah, dude. And not not any dog stuff. Not any dog stuff to be
totally clear. Just a lengthy theory about how they had a relationship
long before he was leaking that himself. But you've responded
to the allegations. How would you do that without linking it?
True, I guess. Um, you mean clicking on it? I've already said
that I look at like documentary evidence from there and I think
it's crazy they dox people but yeah I don't need to share it
around. I mean hold on but even if I had like I assume I would
I don't even I think I broadly like don't link there. I think
I broadly like um if I have like a piece of information, I just
take a screenshot. But yeah, I so really all this po proves is
even if somebody had linked Kiwi Farms, there'd need to be some
intent there, right? It seems to be what he's saying that he's
posted her thread, but it was like essentially to say the harassment
is not coming from me, from somewhere else. Seems like he's saying
this is not a moral wrong. I was I Dude, I was looking for like
the whole I thought I was looking for the whole like Kiwi Farm's
been wrongly blamed. See, what you've got to remember though
is that Destiny didn't write any of this. So, these aren't really
his positions. Anyone that thinks Destiny was writing manifestos
is taking crazy pills. Bro, the honestly the best explanation
for how the last one was is that Tom wrote it. I've seen people
say that. I don't think that's true. I don't think that was what
Tom was saying. But but um the I don't it's kind of crazy to
me that like basically every single bad thing that's happening
to her is blamed on Kiwi Farms when there are other websites
that are working in the background that are arguably doing more
than Kiwi Farms is. But crazy just now Kiwi Farm would be totally
responsible for all those websites. Thanks Destiny.
Like and the the funny thing is is like at least at least the
docs was posted on Kiwi Farms or something, right? Like at least
there are people talking about it on Kiwi Farms. Mhm. At least
there was like probably like some pretty bad moral lines crossed
on gooey farms. In our case, I'm not sure he can attach us to
like any of those things, like anything like that. Like realistically,
when when you got given when Queen got given the Lauren Southern
DMs, he said, "Yeah, I don't feel comfortable publishing this
actually and deleted a bunch of the the guy posting it in his
Discord." Was like, "This is doesn't seem right." I I literally
said to the guy like I think when the only thing I said to him
was, "If you're going to try posting this again, get rid of her
son's name." That was was the like the only thing I said to this
guy was do do not post her son's name. So would you say that
you were you know more or less more concerned about Lawrence
I wouldn't privacy I'm just saying like I saying Destiny was
well I listen I like I said I don't want to sit here and virtue
signal grand cuz I truly I don't care that much but it was just
that the first thing came to my mind was you know immediately
that's Lawrence Southern's kid's name. I I can imagine how [__]
up it could be for Lauren Southern's kid's name to get out because
of who Laurens Southern is. I wouldn't want that to happen to
a kid. You should not release that. That that was my immediate
thought process. Now, you could make a point about how Destiny
handed off those screenshots that included that sensitive information
to not just Rose, but probably other people and how that that's
how it ended up coming across my eyes. And apparently I was engaging
in more due diligence than the Destiny. But yeah, I wouldn't
I wouldn't grandstand about something like that personally. Yeah.
Well, I unfortunately as soon as I start covering some Destiny,
people start hitting me with other Destiny. So, quick. Sorry.
I don't necessarily like want to cover it that badly, but it
is pretty funny when I start getting timestamps of all the he's
been saying for the past couple days. You're linking me an immature
album. Is this related to something? I think you told me was
related to Ry, but hold on. What is this exactly? This is This
is people. Oh, this is the responses to Destiny being called
a pest by Asmin Gold. At least he has. He can't convince me Asmin
Gold is getting cheeks.
Yes. Okay. Asmin isn't afest because he looks in the mirror and
knows there's no way it's going to happen. Uh, Destiny's Bohemian
lifestyle. Crazy. Calling afer who complains about video game
characters not being enough is peak hypocrisy. In what way? Like,
how can you argue this guy's a virgin? actually be as as uh lustful
and and obje objectifying as you want towards video game characters.
You know, you can you can do that as much as you. It's a bit
different when it's people. It's a little bit different when
it's people. It is. Does he even know what that means? I think
I think in his mind would be his favorite. Okay. Wait, what's
with the title? Like that's the one accusation that's distinctly
true about Destiny. He did a crime. In comparison, manipulator
and psychotic are far more outrageous. What was the crime? shared
nudes to to a friend without that someone's consent. To be clear,
this isn't merely an accusation. Destiny admitted it. He did
it. He just thought it was okay for that particular someone.
Why do people lie? Okay, thanks. You So, you weren't looking
for information here. You were trying to get into a debate. Okay,
thanks. From my understanding, didn't she also do something similar?
Like, you already had the information. You were looking for a
debate here. This is a liar. Sure. Yeah. Sure. Sure. Sure. Also,
this is like the guy who's like responding is also lying. Yep.
Or at least Destiny believed so. Destiny didn't believe so. I'm
sorry. That's It's clear he did not. So, uh, bro, how rich is
this? No pun intended. Okay. Are we going through all these?
At least Destiny has How does your response to this guy called
me a pest? At least Destiny has Oh, one second. Okay. Okay. Um,
we live in a world where morality and taking accountability means
all to them. They got their pest. I got mines. I give Oh, that
was a that was one I saw a lot. I don't know if you saw that.
Uh, this guy really like likes Trump but calls destiny a past.
It's just like dude I People have broadly just gotten rid of
their morals. They're just like anything the other anything the
other side does is allowed and Yeah. It's like what weren't you
criticizing Trump for
afra I'm I'm good without reading more of this. I I wanted to
watch whatever the this other time stamp was really quickly.
Somebody said he comments on the Lauren Southern affair. Oh,
he reached out, gave him the benefit of the Destiny, answer my
question, you coward. What's your question? How can you criticize
Idubbbz for platforming Hassan when you were implicitly promoting
Lauren Southern having have showing of her docs on stream so
you could have an affair with her? Hey, know she wasn't trying
to have one with me and that's why she had me show them. Could
have been the other way around. You can bring have showing of
her docs on stream so you could have an affair with her. Hey,
know she wasn't trying to have one with me and that's why she
had me show them. Could have been the other way around. What?
You can bring up any person that I platformed on my stream for
any reason. The difference for all of these, whether it's Lauren,
whether it's Nick Fuentes, whether it's Yo Mama, whether it's
literally anybody at all. Okay? The difference is is I push back
on that I disagree with and that I should disagree with on all
of it. So you can say whatever you want about anybody that I've
platform, but nobody who's ever watched my content has ever come
away from me having a conversation with some person think like,
"Oh my god, I think uh for the Nazis, right, Destiny must be
a full-on Nazi. That's crazy that he's a full like nobody's ever
thought this ever. That's the difference. I I don't know how
hard it is for you to understand that. It was a pretty simple